quelles sont les armes les plus
efficaces contre le complotisme ça c'est
la grosse question d'abord larmes qui
est la moins efficace pour lutter contre
le complotisme le sait la dénonciation
des complotistes
c'est à dire que si vous dites que les
complotistes sont des abrutis des
paranoïaques des malades mentaux des
extrémistes ça ne sert à rien parce qu
ils vous répondront toujours oui mais
vous ne m'avez pas répondu sur le fond
alors ce qui caractérise les
complotistes c'est le fait qu'ils vont
en général a avancé des arguments
techniques ou scientifiques qui risque
de vous laisser sans voix et donc la
grosse difficulté mais c'est à nos yeux
c'est d'arriver à répondre justement aux
complotistes sur le fond c'est-à-dire de
parvenir à connaître suffisamment bien
le dossier pour être capable de démonter
un raisonnement qui semblerait à
première vue l'irréfutable mais qui en
réalité comme c'est le cas pour la 99 9%
des complotistes ne résiste pas à
l'examen critique donc la seule réponse
possible aux groupes l'autisme pour moi
c'est essayer si c'est possible parce
que c'est difficile de répondre sur le
flop
non